Is there such thing as using the right for sheet too much? I sleep with it every night, but I use it
Anytime I am at home relaxing. I know there isn't you know
There's we have some people that are so ill that they're just running 24-7. They're running the right
You cannot get too much right in less. You're running a lime program
That'd be the only thing that should be careful with so anybody that you know
I used to sell a lot more rives to lime patients and we just have not taken lime patients
Unless they've been referred by a patient. We just haven't done that for a long time
And but the rife works fantastic for live disease
But you have to be careful because you could hurt yourself really easy because it works so good and
And you hurt yourself by lime as a gram negative bacteria
When you kill it too quickly you stint will you liberate?
Like a polysaccharides that can thank you sick
If you're already done lime programs, you're running cancer programs. You can't overdo it